entregarse a las autoridades en plena
medianoche como Irene una mujer
camerunesa de 38 años más de 25.000
migrantes se encuentran actualmente en
la frontera sur de Estados Unidos
No tengo otra opción mi vida está en
peligro
a lo largo de la última semana unas Diez
mil personas intentaron cruzar la
frontera de manera clandestina según las
autoridades de la nación americana está
afluencia se produjo justo antes de la
expiración del título 42 una medida que
permitía la devolución inmediata de
todos los migrantes incluidos los
uristantes de asilo para hacer frente a
esta situación la administración
estadounidense endureció el jueves las
normas a partir de ahora antes de
presentarse en la frontera Los
solicitantes de asilo salvo los menores
no acompañados deberán obtener una cita
mediante una solicitud sino se pondrá en
marcha un procedimiento acelerado de
deportación y una prohibición de entrada
a Estados Unidos durante cinco años
la frontera ilegalmente porque sabemos
que hay hay una pena para eso Entonces
vamos a esperar un tiempo en la
aplicación
caótica y una afluencia masiva en la
frontera la administración
mucho porque es muy difícil aportar una
solución a lo que llamamos los factores
de incentivación es decir lo que empuja
a la gente a salir Por lo general hay
razones económicas la crisis climática y
la inseguridad en la frontera la espera
continua la medida diseñada para
centralizar la solicitudes de asilo en
Estados Unidos ya plantea muchos
problemas a los inmigrantes según las
asociaciones sobre el terreno las
franjas horarias son escasas solo el 10%
de los migrantes consiguen una cita